I'm happy to call this man bless this
mess is in season number two on ABC
Tuesday nights at 8:30 p.m. Eastern 7:30
p.m. central the very funny David
Koechner vacuum hi good to see you sir
may I say something
I see where his friendship and raise you
won best
Wow yeah oh really I mean it's up to you
[Music]
[Laughter]
friends BFFs forever well I don't go any
other way okay highs and lows I'd
understand okay I raised you a forever
then I see your forever and I call your
friend here's my cards all angels know I
wasn't sitting down and there wasn't
this large pumpkin at the end of my desk
I'd come right around and know and give
you a hug the pumpkins pumpkin I know
you're you're big enough to go ahead and
do that by the way nice Chiefs golf
shirt you got no no it's time it's
Chiefs season some people call it
football season yes I call it chief
season no no so you could you could
technically use this and pull a
Stonestreet put the hat on to the
mustache and go as Andy Reed tonight you
could slightly slimmer Andy yes it's a
recognizable idea now do you get into
the spirit of Halloween or you are you
going Halloween II you are treating
tonight the twins we have five children
as you know yes the twins are in eighth
grade
so there's hopefully some mischief honey
where do the eggs go in our refrigerator
it's gone shaving cream and eggs pretty
much doesn't exist I just date myself
no okay does it matter there are things
that the children finally think oh I
wish that still happened yes my son
sergeant last night he's in eighth grade
asked me if I had televisions when I was
growing up come on have TV in the house
dad like the twilight zone and he's like
an old Rod Serling episode
black-and-white yeah yeah okay
they're trying to over explain how great
rod serling is yes please don't talk
during the opening monologue of The
Twilight Zone and then he's going on
saying well what is this woman think
this is happening but it's not really
having us at Sun it's the Twilight Zone
it's the space between reality and
unreality
that's the Twilight Zone that's the name
of the show yes so like she thinks it's
happening said whatever you believe jess
is the truth son so one of one of the
William Shatner's greatest work was uh
was a was a Twilight Zone right and
burgess Meredith oh did you ever did you
ever see Twilight Zone okay the burgess
Meredith one where he has glasses and
all he wants to do is read books and
there's a nuclear war and he's all by
himself himself into a bank vault
accidentally yes and then go ahead his
glasses are broken and he can't read the
books it's uh it's steeped in irony that
qualifies as irony spoiler alert
did with his spoiler we just it's fine
you know it's 15 60 years the joy of
that one yes if you still watch it and
already know the end right you'll still
love it there's so many great ones like
that so why did he why would your son
ask you if you had a television when you
grew up well you know I didn't have a
cell phone that's fact you know yes you
hear about stuff like that just one
telephone line yes I don't know why it
occurred to him that we didn't have
television I tried to explain it was his
age I try to explain to my
eight-year-old the other day about what
an encyclopedia was y-you know what I
sold encyclopedias for one week in
Kansas City out of here so where'd you I
was a door-to-door encyclopedia salesman
in Kansas City yes I came after my
sophomore year in college I decided I'm
not going back to Tipton Missouri where
I'm from mm people I'm gonna go to
Kansas City I got some buddies their
friend Ed from college my dad said okay
well you have to have X number of
dollars saved just before you go back to
school yes because I'm not just you know
paying for everything so I had a series
of jobs one selling cable one selling
encyclopedias one selling circus delight
ice cream none of which panned out just
a job after job
how many encyclopedias did you sell none
zero there was a 10 page come on script
you had to go into people's houses and
they'll just take away script yes you
believe education is important yes of
course
great so do I it was just not sure
you're really committed to your children
if you don't believe we should get
dropped off in the neighborhoods like
10:45 at night yeah I'm like I don't
think this job is the right one not to
top you that you topped me at the birds
ever forever
there's only communion here so this is
my favorite story by the way one of my
first jobs I ever had was cold calling
Brooklyn and Staten Island residence for
the New York Post at Saturday morning
8:00 a.m. and the language I heard yeah
it's not even safe for certain types of
work yeah yeah I could not and I would
sell eventually the newspaper to people
who hardly spoke English and it was
terrible I thought they had I don't even
think they knew what the hell the New
York Post was right I mean at 8:00 in
the morning on a Saturday just call
people up you know
yeah what art do you have do you
subscribe to New York Post no I do not
like what would you like I mean it was
terrible oh my gosh and then what what
do you remember the pitch at all oh it
was just yeah I mean you know how would
you like to get the most New York or
something stupid like that or but a lot
of people don't pick up no or if they do
they're just really not interested in
subscribing to a newspaper confused and
then irate so did you so did you get you
didn't even get close to something no no
no no not even close
I mean talking line up do you care about
education I could I only memorize the
first page so had I got into a sale I
would not have known what to do
david koechner here on the Rich Eisen
show so are you going are you are you
dressing up and tonight I probably wear
a mask
what do you that's it well yeah that's
it you're just gonna wear a mask I'm
mostly you know security okay you get
the light you're really I'm really over
diligent about well what hold your
course course hold your car I mean you
can do that still in garb you could
still dress up okay and because I'm
I'm going trick-or-treating tonight oh
you dress I am do you watch the Great
British Bake Show I don't that was my
opening line to sell the New York Post
know what we do as a family so there's a
guy on the Great British Bake show named
Knowle he's a comedian in the UK and I'm
dressing up a saying okay what is it
particulars he's got long hair don't
care about he's got well I'm gonna wig
which right there on the screen I'm
going to turn that guy on the right Wow
foolish go ahead where's all sorts of
crazy costumes and unpinning and shirts
and all that sort of stuff and I might
seeing some eyeliner and I'm gonna go
with a guy liner tonight and I saw my
wife Suzie who you know will apply the
guyliner before we go ahead out into the
mean streets of Studio City it's a smart
as a costume it doesn't impede your
progress at all and I could still flash
the flash little flash the flash light
and then you get you know who the real
hipsters are now they're like you get it
you get it no no yep extra extra large
candy bars maybe nothing for the kids in
honor of Udo I'm going right now
as a member of big slick society I love
what my big slick hat on right here then
I got many many many moons ago for your
fantastic charity for Children's Mercy
Hospital there in case you don't you you
and Stonestreet and Ruud and wriggle and
wriggle and you all get together and
yeah you raised over two million pounds
this year long we moved to the Sprint
Center unbelievable yeah we almost
canceled the whole thing because you
couldn't make it this you know no I was
able to say no no yes leave rich out of
this yes I mean this was hours of
arguing it was because again that's the
BFF thing right no I got you almost
stopped the whole fundraising process
but you've done this for 10 years 10 yo
life you're going we are going alone
okay we're back the whole thing's gonna
run it back you can see the Sprint
Center in front of all but you had
10,000 people there last time someone
zero citations okay six ish okay yeah
yeah I'd like to enhance that is amazing
and you've raised how much over the last
year's it's over ten million
David that is really unbelievable pretty
good and it's a family affair
everybody's folks and families involved
and it's fun though isn't it it's
amazing as a fund raiser and you've been
to hundreds yes it's got to be among the
best it is it really is well because
again we're looking on the screen right
here and you see big Weird Al Yankovic
and you and the Jake Tapper Jake Tapper
and at the hospital visiting the kids
yeah and it's funny you know about how
you guys you and Riggle kind of you are
the muscle and by that I mean all of the
celebrity guests that did come out from
everywhere go out on a Friday night or
go to the hospitality Suites at the
place where you put us up right and it's
1:00 in the morning and and and nobody's
thinking about going to bed at all you
and Riggle will walk up to every single
person and just stand right in front of
them and go you know you got a 7 a.m.
yeah that we have to go to the hospital
see the kids and and you look you and
your big dude and so is Riggle and and
we're like okay Sunday but yeah and you
guys do all that and it really is
amazing what you guys do is is truly
remarkable david koechner here on the
Rich Eisen show bless this mess airs
Tuesdays at 8:30 p.m. on ABC we have Pam
Grier on to talk about
although several months ago you and dak
Shepherd lake bell at Begley Jr you know
Dax and Laker are fish out of water if
you will from a big city and baskets its
Green Acres ok set now ok
they had a farmhouse the inherited goes
back there things could be wonderful
like his childhood right ain't what he
thought it was gonna be exactly but the
town learns from them and they learned
from the town right it's more the
community show with a family inside so
how far off are you playing your
character here well you know as you know
in every character I do I go deep though
be if I find what's the essence of this
guy yes
he's he's selfish he's a bit shy yes so
then the heartland of the country
everybody has their own proclivities
it's deep inside that there's no we're
nesting there's a type of fear that's
deep sea that you're actually covering
up and think oh how can I just let this
out a little bit it's it's a lot of fun
the writing is so good on the show it's
not like any of the characters you've
seen me play before he's got more of a
heart yes these less inclined to bombast
and or but dare I say misogyny and
racism like that no kindly and you're
saying though folks I'm not like that
I'm ironically playing those characters
to bring light to what awful people
might be That's not me
David Koechner everybody that's a full
round of applause okay wait you didn't
that's just Casey being case in case
it's a clap one time no come on now
okay let's play start bench cut what
David Koechner we haven't played start
bench cut in a while you're gonna have
to we're gonna give you three choices
yes sir start one bench one in audios
okay okay here he goes now the first one
first one up for bids here to use the
prices right phrase we asked of
Stonestreet okay so we might compare and
contrast so you have best Kansas City
barbecue Oh ribs chicken burnt ends
let's start one bench one and caught one
what bench oh I cut I cut burnt ends
that's just not my thing I start ribs
and you oh yeah if I'm not mistaken
burnt ends was a first team all start
for Stonestreet like he actually
insisted that we we include that so you
could start it right it's okay so
preference this guy did it's fine
so you just you just cut burn ends
before I don't even consider it I mean
I'm in my mid-50s
so my consideration is what's going on
an hour and what you're going to what's
you're going to spot when you go there
let's put you on the terrible spot see
I'm not from Kansas City
so my go-to spot is my brother-in-law
Tim hand ok does a nice smoky okay oh my
goodness he did a pork loin last time I
was in town was just unbelievable so
my sister Cecilia is house okay with
some smoky from from Tim hand okay you
know and you need a personal invitation
obviously to go so I think it's an open
invitation and by by virtue of you being
my best friend for till the end of days
you have an open invitation so you're in
KC or you're just outside of KC you want
some nice smoky pork loin I'll call Tim
gets up next one for for david koechner
start bench cut if you david koepp guess
you had to pick one person to go on
vacation with Ron burgandy Brian Fantana
brick Tamland you though you're not
playing champ kind
it's you David Koechner they go on
vacation with one of these three guys
well it's tough burgandy Fantana or
Tamland who would it be
I think burgandy because he's gonna get
you the most range of free stuff and
insistence on best everything those
restaurants whether they didn't even
know who he is or not he's gonna say
we'll take the Presidential Suite you
know wherever you are so that's a start
that's a start oh okay Oh people know he
got to just get rid of one you can hit
another one that's really hard
Oh cuz I but these aren't real people no
these aren't the real people these are
the characters
I guess I'd say you're cutting rod or
you're kind not right I would
Fantana and I've had to cut brick
because your entire vacation desk would
be just chasing brick brick that's a
fishbowl brick no you can't dream from
there brick right right yeah brick kill
the guy right I mean not confirm or deny
okay here we go
last one for you David Koechner fourth
and goal from the 2 yard line in the
Super Bowl
Oh fourth and goal from the 2 yard line
to win the Super Bowl
who do you want with the ball to make
the play fourth and goal from the to
hear your choices
the Nigerian nightmare Christian Okoye a
Patrick mahomes priest hauls from the
two from the two to win the Superbowl
start bench cut okay
[Music]
I'm gonna go a what so I'll start a call
a yes I will so tough this is hard no
I'm gonna start mahomes I will bench a
call you and III I'm not cutting priest
Holmes I mean I'm gonna I'm gonna say
not your night kid not on the waterfront
folks you should have looked after me a
little bit I mean here's the thing a
coin he's gonna get in there but Holmes
is gonna go nope nope yep and he's not
gonna hurt his Achilles is is a patella
I know he's into recovery but I mean
maja was gonna make the right choice in
that split-second he's gonna see it
anyway already knows everybody's
proclivities I think I've heard that
he's got a photographic memory had been
I I wouldn't put it past i but that's
not part of the scuttlebutt now I don't
know I think you know they always try to
put a new defense in there but my guess
is after the first quarter he's already
seen everything is okay I know it's
gonna happen boo boo boo boo boo David
Koechner you are a national treasure sir
and a best friend forever bless this
mess Tuesdays at 8:30 p.m. and 7:30
central right here on ABC David Koechner
here on the show Edward Norton is in
studio our number three well when we
come back with question before yo well
when are we in tattoos five minutes wow
you had two artists here Wow oh you see
you're actually just I do Mike's got a
sharpie okay all right
it's permanent yes I'm just saying I
like David Koechner on both Twitter
Instagram for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on VR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app